[Musik]
das war mal der friedhof michele in kiew
doch die totenruhe ist hier grausam
zerbombt
krater durchziehen die landschaft es ist
die pure zerstörung die diese drohen
aufnahmen zeigen
bei den russischen luftangriffen auf die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew wird der
friedhof zu großen teilen zerstört
gräber sind kaum noch zu erkennen
grabsteine liegen zerbrochen in der
gegend herum auch auf dem friedhof ein
spezieller bereich in dem verstorbene
ukrainische soldaten begraben sind
schätzungen der vereinten nationen
zufolge wurden in der ukraine seit
beginn des krieges am 24 februar
mindestens
2787 zivilisten getötet und 3000 152
weitere verletzt es wird befürchtet dass
die tatsächliche zahl noch viel höher
ist
[Musik]